the whole world is going to crap if you
believe that you just may deserve to be
slapped so despite the administration
raising their limit so they could charge
more in the car the United States is
still being downgraded now the markets
are plunging people are rioting in the
streets and a lot of folks are just
getting a raw deal so if the media is so
quick to react to tragedy in both sides
of the political spectrum playing
football with people's real life issues
it's very easy to get down and that's
why I think it's so important to
remember just how blessed most of us
truly are sure you may have a tough but
someone else always has it tougher my
father used to tell me a story when I
was a boy about people with all
different kinds of problems getting
together they would write their problem
on a slip of paper put it in a hat pass
that hat around and at the end of the
day they could all pull out any problem
of their choosing and they all pulled
out the exact same problem that they'd
originally put in the point is that I
don't believe any of us are given more
than we can handle which is why I wanted
to tell you the story of my friends Joel
Scribner an entrepreneur a Taekwondo
world champion and a successful youth
pastor what you may not know unless
you've read his new book supernatural
you however is that Joel's daughter died
at 18 months of age
it is a very very hard chapter to read
for a lot of people it's the story of
the loss of my daughter really how my
life crashed and I felt like I'd lost
everything because my daughter died of
brain cancer just in the beginning of my
career in ministry so I questioned
everything was extremely hard I still
weep every time I read it and reread it
but in that moment I mean I remember my
mom calling me and we had gone to church
that morning and calling me that my
daughter had stopped breathing so I
drove home like a maniac and throwing my
coat off and running into the back
bedroom where she was and started doing
CPR on her and we did CPR for two hours
and it was the lowest parts of my life
when I had to stop and had to give up
and just went against everything that a
parent whatever dude would be just stop
and give up but I had to really I said
to let go and I'll allow her to go and
be where she was supposed to be the wild
thing is I you know I stayed in ministry
I'm still in ministry it's what I do
I work for people I serve people and my
job is to bring hope and help people
find hope but for me I did regress and I
went through a lot of things and I had
it I had to rihwan battles that I
already won in the past but for me
finding my escape was in God that I
could have hope in him and put my faith
in him and he could make sense of the
things that I couldn't make sense of
myself that was really the answer for me
you know the basically the premise of my
book the supernatural you is all about
how you can learn how to tap into
something that's greater than what you
see right in front of you most people
live in the natural realm and they never
understand or realize how actually real
and truly real the supernatural realm is
so what I would say to those people is
that they can't live their life based on
just what they see but we're called to
live a life of faith for me was
but the but I've learned how to believe
it you have learned how to stand tall
again learn how to be confident again
and I haven't said that anybody can to
find
the point I'm making is this sure things
are tough and for a lot of us things are
tougher than they've been in a long
while but as a country we've faced
massive world wars depressions that we
couldn't even imagine and thousands of
our innocent civilians have been killed
by acts of hatred we've seen tougher
times and just as surely you may be
looking at your portfolio or your
checking account thinking this is the
end but you have to know that there are
people out there who have dealt with
tragedy that you can't even begin to
imagine and right now you can allow all
of this the media the uncertainty the
fear to defeat you or you can allow this
to be at the defining moment in your
life for the greatest success story that
you will ever experience
just as if the United States gets its
act together we do the right thing if we
stop charging things to the credit card
and paying out the country's worst most
abysmal failures we can in will be as
great or greater than we've ever been
[Music]